this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Bill and thanks everyone for
the invitation to spend the day with you
folks here unfortunately I won't be
continuing the Allen Marjorie and Chris
show I'm not Canadian but being from
Boston I can give you an earful of
unrecognizable pronunciations of words
while on that that subject in my in Jets
country or bills country today all right
i just wanted to stir the pot a little
bit i'm going to run through okay bill
I'd like you I'm standing between you
folks and lunch I'd rather it be Bill
standing between you and lunch so when
am I Walker okay I'm going to continue
on with a few things built bill started
family business blah blah blah Allen
Michigan State 1980 I followed you Ohio
State 1982 we've been a lot of miles on
our tread but I think everyone here is
very energetic energized and and I don't
think we need to measure ourselves in
terms of years it's more of the energy
that we're all trying to share and
continue experiencing alright reality
check folks very shortly this planet
will be inhabited by nine billion
individuals my question is how many more
until feeding ourselves becomes a
problem I saw a very sobering show on TV
last week that stated that fifty percent
of the Earth's animal species are gone
and the decline is is going to continue
we're displacing lots of other species
how are you going to feed ourselves for
my personal story I
shifted all of my research activity from
three years ago where I was only
researching ornamental crops to today
where 90% of my research activity is
edible crops and I'll show an aerial
photograph of my family's operation and
and over in a slide or to the umbrella
project that I'm writing and speaking
about I've titled from flowers to food
and actually because I grew up on a
truck farm as as a youngster and through
high school it's kind of poetic that
it's really not from flowers to food for
me it's a complete closing of a circle
and it started as food we went to
flowers when we could not make a living
in New England on the farm and I don't
know how balanced or appropriate
inappropriate whatever adjective you
want to use that now my family's
operation three years ago we shut the
doors after 51 years of growing flowers
because there wasn't enough margin to
keep let's see two brothers me my
parents for households going so anyway
I'm very excited about opportunities and
I want to share that excitement with you
after a couple of additional sobering
thoughts a fado wings when they
overpopulate host plants and fly to
another we're building rockets today so
that when we overpopulate not if but
when we overpopulate the planet we can
find a new home a host plant a host
planet silly me for thinking that we're
any smarter than anything so I do
believe we're smart enough but then I
turn on the TV and see a show with a
couple that has 17 children and and you
know what what is this all about every
one of those souls is precious but I
would look at the parents and say I wake
up a bit now is our industrial model of
agriculture sustainable we came
back from World War two and applied an
industrial model to our agricultural
system because it works so well to get
us through the war and it has served us
well in agriculture for two or three
generations many of us in this room will
now look at California Arizona
agriculture and and say is it
sustainable is it going to be the answer
for us I want to continue as seamlessly
as I can with chris is Chris's final
slide with the uptick in locally grown
and whether it's cut flowers or I'm
going to be talking about vegetable
production specifically i'll talk about
root crops in plug trays for any of us
that have been growing flower plugs and
ornamentals for most of our careers I've
got some real cool pictures to share
with you of radishes beets and carrots
and how we might be able to hit these
locally grown food movement with some of
our expertise can we return agriculture
to the family farm this is a farmer's
market in emmaus Pennsylvania and what I
found very interesting with this I'm
guessing well that's that's a matriarch
that is a lynchpin a a backbone of our
greenhouse industry I've got my mom
that's been the central key point the
glue that holds things together I know
any other person in this audience that
is on a family-run operation you know
this position that I'm describing I
don't know I didn't talk to this group
to decide whether or learn whether it's
her daughter and son-in-law or her son
and daughter-in-law but there's the
second generation and then so cool that
we've got that third generation waiting
in the wings to continue this family
farm approach here's a grower less than
an hour from me in
in eastern Massachusetts a
multi-generational family farm you can
look out the the glass glazing of
sidewall of the greenhouse and see
traditional outdoor row crop agriculture
now this family operation is is an
integrated horticultural establishment
today where they grew up on the farm had
a farm stand build greenhouses got
involved and diversified into flowers
along with the farm and what's really
cool here I stood in there and I saw it
at this point what I determined was the
future of some of our agriculture these
are baby greens being broadcast zone in
rows in open 10-20 trays on a flood and
drain or urban flood bench and they were
harvesting this this crop in three weeks
from so to harvest and they had the farm
stand right there on site so that was
really cool for me to see the past or
the traditional agriculture with with
the future few questions would we be
healthier eating less but higher quality
food what did high fructose corn syrup
accomplish isn't it nice to see some of
the manufacturers now listening and
getting away from that input and why
does our food have to be so cheap I was
this past Sunday I saw one of the early
morning news programs and there was a
segment and I don't have the name of it
right but it was it was about the
movement to pay migrant farmworkers a
more fair wage and how the movement hit
its head against the wall for many years
going to the grocery stores saying we
need you to pay a little more for the
produce so that we can pay the Pickers
and it wasn't until they bypassed
distribution and went right to the
consumer that they got the necessary
momentum and it is the pro
something like fair fair food or
something but it struck me because I
have a real issue with why in the United
States our food has to be so cheap and
why as growers and we it's all about
what costs can we take out versus what
quality can we put in so the locally
grown food movement with all these
participants increasing I think that's
really cool now I'm going to toggle back
and forth between a farmer's market in
Boulder Colorado that I visited last
year and took some really neat pictures
I'm going to ask you to from time to
time squint your eyes I'm going to show
you some really nice produce in the
stalls and stands of the farmers market
and then I'm going to toggle back to my
research greenhouse and activities and
in the end say is there a difference
between the pictures that we're looking
at this is that aerial up view of the
family operation in Massachusetts 55,000
square feet down the off the slide when
I grew up before this land was sold to
settle my grandfather's estate we had
about 10 acres of land that we
cultivated and we trucked our produce
into Boston if any of you been in the
faneuil hall tourist area of boston
before converting it to a tourist
location i have memories of driving in
with my dad in the pickup truck loaded
with the produce right to those
buildings and unloading in the stall
where a commission agent would then sell
the produce so at this point we've shut
down the family operation one of my
brother's is running a few houses for
flower production to complement his
landscaping activities and I've taken
over one house a 2500 foot house for for
my research projects inside this house
today is completely
we retooled for greenhouse hydroponic
vegetable and our production nutrient
film channels flood and drain benches
now this is a 72 plug plug tray of
radishes and Marjorie Allen any of us in
research we look back on your careers
and you were lucky if we have you know a
handful of pictures that we call winners
and money shots and this one as a matter
of fact is about 20 years old so before
I ever thought of researching radishes
you know the saying you take the boy off
the farm but you don't take the farm out
of the boy for years I had a corner of a
greenhouse that I would grow fresh
vegetables for for just my family's
consumption and as I was the one doing
the sewing and plug producing on our
operation it didn't take long to use my
imagination and start growing some
radishes so so that that is an old
picture and what I found really
interesting is I'm going to show you a
few more pictures from this past year
where I'm digging into the research side
of this a little bit more let's talk
about to boulder for a moment look at
all those root crops ladies and
gentlemen from the turnips beets the
carrots the colors the freshness the
farmers market locally grown food this
whole thing I find very exciting I find
I'm very fortunate to be able to
research the in this area travel around
the country and learn and learn as much
as I can about the young generation of
consumers that is telling us they want
locally grown food they're also telling
us that they'd like to eat seasonally
and I describe my generation as being
spoiled where the grocery store
supermarket generation where over our
lives wasn't it so cool that any day of
the year we could go to the grocery
or get anything from any place on the
planet and now our children are saying
that's that's not sustainable Alan
you've referenced your daughter often in
your presentation our children are
probably up similar ages and I'm
crediting them when I'm with them saying
you guys are fueling this you're going
to change the way we feed ourselves this
is a picture of a crop of radishes that
I grew last year the long icicle shape
look at the different colors and oh by
the way that's a carrot shaped like a
radish so one of my messages for fellow
growers in the audience is guys this is
the only how far will our imagination
take us Alan did a great job talking
about reading and and the opportunities
that are just there and there's a
project I have a second project looking
at LED lighting and indoor warehouse
food production and in my opinion the
reading efforts the cultivars that we
need for those production systems are
right around the corner waiting for us
this is a 5 inch deep nursery blood tray
ok let's grow it let's get going we can
grow some carrots we can grow some beets
this is a the Nanta type carrot with
that wide shoulder this is a 50 plug
tray with the 5 inch deep you know
intended for nursery stock and that's a
that's pretty cool crop now cultivar
selection is important so most of the
cultivars that I'm showing pictures of
today when I was selecting them in seed
catalogs they were always described with
the words miniature fast crop you know
you don't want to try and grow an 8 inch
long carrot in a 5 inch deep plug tray
but how cool some of these this was a
trial with two different cultivars and
and how cool we match up the cultivar
with the
plug traian and we're good to go here's
a turnip and I have this picture to
illustrate the following I want to call
your attention to the external route mat
from that plug tray now anyone in this
room who's grown ornamental crop plugs
we do we go out of our way to make sure
that doesn't happen we don't want roots
external to the plug tray I found after
one round of work that's exactly what I
do want in this crop so we have to turn
what we've learned on its ear from time
to time and here's where I see
production of this group of crops going
I'd like to see a new plug trade
designed with instead of maximum cell
volume that we want for petunias and
geranium plugs I'd like minimum cell
volume the growing medium in my opinion
in this system is only to support the
seed and allow it to germinate once the
root gets down to the flood end drain
environment this interface is where all
action is so I see a new plug trays
designed for this type of food crop
production where much significantly less
growing mix will go into the plug tray
because we only need that route to get
down to the outside a couple of slides
showing how cultivars are different this
is a miniature white turnip and it was
very easy to harvest with two fingers
just pulling it and that fairly weak
taproot would slide right out of the
ground its mate a red turnip was much
different where it's at deeper in the
growing mix and you'd need two hands to
remove the roots from that turnip so
there's an opportunity for us and plant
readers to develop cultivars that will
sit on top of the mix for harvesting
purposes and I always like to show
slides where we can say you know it's
fun to grow plants and it's fun to work
with plants for a living harvest size
maturity we certainly need to match
those things up depending on the density
of the cell and how many you're trying
to grow in a square foot versus how long
are we going to grow them and we can get
real cute with this trying to fit round
pegs in square holes two hands weren't
enough to get that out i needed a
jackhammer let's go to radishes for a
few slides set and this this research
this experiment was looking at density
and in yield so I had on the left a 72
plug tray a 105 and a 128 and after
growing to maturity I removed the tops
of the plants to take this picture the
72 plug tray the 105 to 128 and then
went a step further harvested Wade did
all that so the left-hand row is the 72
105 128 if I'm not going to quickly the
bottom row is what we'd say is
acceptable market size the largest ones
then in the middle is an intermediate
medium sized radish and then some pea
size small radishes up above so as we
would predict the the larger cell size
the 72 tray produced the highest
proportion of large radishes too small
and as we got into a tighter
configuration with 128 we had more of
the medium and small ok what's it all
mean I brought those home and took the
marketable ones and sliced them as you
and I do for our salads and instead of
saying these are not marketable the
medium and small-sized I started
imagining well with a smaller size
radish we don't have to slice it
probably get our fingers before we get
the slices of the radish but we might
just cut it
half and sprinkle it on the salad and
then instead of throwing out these piece
size they were actually the size of
green olives so I got to thinking this
happened to be after a couple of
home-brewed beers that afternoon and by
the way my garden Helen I used to have a
25 x 30 vegetable garden off the end of
my house I started home brewing beer
about eight years ago it didn't take two
years for the vegetables to go in the
hops too so I've got a wall of hops the
size of this screen screaming to be
harvest in the next day or two anyways
is this imagination why can't we grow a
radish that doesn't need to be sliced
and sprinkled like a green olive the
only downside I see is an oil-based of
salad dressing some of these trying to
stab them or the fork might end up on
what movie was that where it it ended up
on a neighbor's plate alright this is a
288 plug tray of radish just to see how
far the envelope can be pushed and it's
almost blurring a line between being a
sprout or being a radish so I'm going to
do some work continue there and see
where it leads I think some some some
growth regulation I'm dying to look at
some floor out work on on systems like
this from years ago I've had slides of
geranium cuttings where it appeared that
they were rooted more heavily after
floral treatment on a stock plant or in
a plug tray and my reasoning back then
was where we're encouraging vegetative
growth and the root is a vegetative
organs so I want to take that little
concept and see if it will translate and
and produce a uniform radish with a
smaller top now this is dangerous before
lunch but your conference organizers
asked me to put a little economics into
this presentation so I'm going to go
through about five minutes and give you
might might take which is a bit
untraditional on how we look at some of
our production costs but just bear with
me for it for a few slides this is on
the handout for those of you that might
want to take these tables home with you
first we want to handle a discussion of
overhead costs and the left-hand column
is a traditional dollars per square foot
per week as a means of describing
overhead costs the column I added next
to it is multiplying that per square
foot per week out by 52 weeks just to
get an idea just to get wrap our arms
around how much is it costing for us to
remember the title of this presentation
is from flowers to food so my premise is
that many of us in the audience are
currently growing ornamental crops some
of us might not be satisfied with the
money we're making on flowers and we
might be looking at a corner of a
greenhouse a Bay of a range a section of
the operation to convert from flowers to
food so I thought it would be good to to
go through some traditional cost
analysis in the end we're going to be
faced with saying okay I can make more
per square foot growing flowers so
that's what I'll grow or I can make more
per square foot growing vegetables
that's what I'm going to do in those
square feet so the following columns are
taking square foot per week and
converting it to a 10-20 tray so with 10
20 tray is 1.6 square feet and that's
what I'm going to do in these columns
then we're going to look at various crop
cycles just to fill things in a bit so
as an example a very fairly common
square foot per week overhead cost is 25
cents and if we look at 25 cents in a
10-20 tray for a three-week crop cycle
it would be a dollar twenty four
are your overhead costs are we okay
there if we go to four weeks six weeks
eight weeks now what do these cycles
matchup with four vegetable crops this
would be the baby greens radish four
weeks turnip more like six weeks carrots
eight weeks all right so just for us to
wrap our arms around it i'm not asking
you to memorize or you know just just
for a introductory conversation so i'm
going to concentrate on the column for
radish just for simplicity today and
we'll come back to that in a moment so
you've got that table you can do
whatever you want with it variable cost
per tray 72 tray 128 288 again looking
at this radish example that I'm I'm
running through catalog tray prices very
similar for these three different trays
I'm assuming we can use a tray for four
crops with some sanitizing in between
crops so that brings that variable cost
down into the 40-cent range then we look
at the growing medium which i assume is
fairly similar because the 72 cell is a
larger cell but fewer cells right we
start adding cells but the cell size
decreases so I kind of comes out in the
wash and you follow that argument
through the tray in the media 75 80
cents or tray and then the one that does
change is the as variable cost is the
cost of the radish seeds so when we go
from 72 seeds up to 288 seeds then we've
got more money that we're putting into
that tray so add all those things up
folks and we're looking at somewhere
under over a dollar right another word
round number is this is very chunky big
chunk cost analysis now this this one
this part I wanted well many of us as
small growers are guilty of not
factoring into our
now sees our salaries many small
operations wait till the end of the
season and whatever's left in their
pocket ends up being his or her salary
as the small business owner so I want to
kind of play on that off of that a bit
and I'm going to approach this
differently so I'm going to to say how
much of the greenhouse range am i
considering shifting over to food crops
and once I decide how much room I have
how much money do I want left in my
pocket at the end of the year all right
so if I'm balancing whether your
geraniums or radishes for me to change
from geraniums to radishes it's got to
put more money in my pocket so the way
I'm going through this this little table
is for instance if i'm going to put
10,000 square feet or a quarter of an
acre into radish production and pleased
with me I'm saying radishes but I'm
meaning anything edible okay if I want
to make 25 thousand dollars off of that
10,000 square feet my overhead cost is
going to go up by a nickel a square foot
for a week does that make sense in other
words I'm factoring in my salary what do
I want my salary to be to justify going
into the vegetable crops if I want to
make $50,000 naturally it's going to
contribute more to the overhead costs
and then if I fill things in a little
bit the more space I want to put into
vegetable crops the lower that overhead
cost becomes if I want to make a lot of
money I'm probably going to want to put
a lot of space into production all right
enough back to this slide let's now zero
in on and finish this little thread
talking about radishes starting with
that common 25-cent overhead now if on
the previous slide i said i want to make
10,000 doll
five thousand dollars 10,000 square feet
it contributes a nickel that nickel of
overhead per square foot per week will
translate into thirty cents per tray
right and i know this dangerous right
before lunch going going through this
i'm glad the lights are up shift gears
now I went into the grocery store this
this well I took a morning this was fun
this was good research i went to walmart
i never go to walmart I Walmart is the
evil empire for me that's yeah everybody
hear that all right no spell check on
this guy so Walmart my local regional
store is called market basket and then I
went in whole foods so as expected Whole
Foods was the highest bunch of radishes
two dollars for the bunch there were
only nine radishes but it was organic
although the walmart ninety-four cents
the cheapest there were 12 radishes in
the bunch at my local chain this was the
bag of radishes without the greens that
you're familiar with 23 in there say two
dozen and they also had the live bunch
with greens 99 cents blah blah blah
alright so they need not really
interesting to you but you know I
weighed the fresh way cleaner pops off
weight / radish all that stuff but but
the point that i want to bring out here
is is this range of retail costs and
from this range i chose a dollar forty
nine as the retail price that i'm going
to use in the analysis next step i'm
assuming that we have eighty-five
percent yield in these various plug
trays so at a 72 tray eighty-five
percent yield will give us five bunches
of a dozen each if we're selling at a
dollar forty nine
the revenue 760 blah blah blah okay this
slide kind of summarizes it the overhead
costs that I was zeroing in on range
from a dollar 62 220 for variable cost
of the total production cost to 48 23 37
and again this is this big chunky cost
analysis the potential revenue 762 10 13
from the previous slide so so it is more
a proof of concept folks does it even
make sense to do this we know we can
grow them but is he going to make money
for us to to shift and this this first
time through with these numbers the
revenue is higher than the cost by
enough that I want to keep pushing a
pencil right so so i think my first year
in this project was proof of concept in
terms of the production of the crop once
we determine that it's only our
imagination we can grow anything we want
in a hydroponic environment then we
pressed on the economics a little bit in
the numbers at least right now are there
so so i think that we're going to be in
in good shape we munch mention local
adult I mean a young adults asking for
locally grown food they want to eat
what's in season this is key so far this
generation is willing to pay a premium
and I want to keep them away from
walmart and not poison them with this
cheap is best they're saying that my
earlier question would we be healthier
eating less but higher quality food
they're saying yes yes we want that here
is that Boulder farmers market showing
the diversity and tomatoes this slide
really intrigued me because the cut
flowers in the lower right are showing
us this diversified horticulture where
we've got flora culture in with the food
production and the what struck me is the
interaction the intimacy of the farmer
to consumer relationship
and that's something that we don't have
in a supermarket or grocery store any of
us in garden centering we've always held
hung our hats on quality and service the
service part being that that intimacy
with our with our customer Alan kudos
for the app and bringing more education
to this whole table so that we can all
do a better job as with flowers folks
anchor in specialty items particularly
local populations ethnic preferences
breeding is going to bring all kinds of
opportunities when bright lights Swiss
chard was released years ago it blurred
the line between the flower garden and
the vegetable garden we've talked today
about the deck becoming the garden and
it's going to be blurred lines between
food crops and ornamentals we have
carrots shaped like radish beats shaped
like carrots it's like whatever we ask
plant breeders to give us they will and
I find that very exciting here is par
koi in in an ebb and flood environment
the deep nursery tray at harvest this
slide if in particular illustrates the
cultivar selection part of this process
so in a in a high density planting we
want to go more for the smaller compact
miniature cultivars so that we can avoid
the diseases and avoid the missteps in
production we can also force these into
a this a 50 sell trade grown more as a
baby green and you've seen that product
in the grocery store this is a pristine
glacial lake in Colorado unfortunately I
use it to to make a couple of comments
about fresh water and I think in our
lifetimes we're going to see that Wars
will not be fought over a few fossil
fuels Wars will be fought over water I
think we're already witnessing
this in the state of California where
the battle is between municipalities and
agriculture and if i were to put my
money on who's going to win i think it's
going to be municipalities so we need to
figure this out and we need to do it
quickly i think i'm going to skip
through final question can we return all
of our agriculture to the local level my
opinion no we can't we can't completely
displace industrialized agriculture
there's I don't think there's enough
room to do all of this but I do see a
significant portion of agriculture being
returned to its local roots and with
this field of celery that I stood at in
Southern California I brought that
feeling home and did some work with
celery this past season looking at in
1801 sell a 37 and a 72 and what was
really cool about this 80 days after
plant these three planets look very
similar in that hydroponic environment
where you can you can see where we don't
need all that growing medium anymore if
we are delivering the nutrients in that
irrigation stream anymore more frequent
cycling and then that harvest brought
those home on the under breadboard and
again the imagination squinting our eyes
can we can we adapt and not have to have
a huge stock or plant of celery that
we're currently buying in the
supermarket can we buy smaller stocks of
celery that will allow me to grow it in
a shorter crop cycle so that I can make
a living growing celery for the local
market I'll close with this in my
experience if I talk carrots and celery
when I'm buying them in my local grocery
store I've learned the hard way less
than half the time when I come home that
celery is tender and sweet less than
half the time the other times it's
bitter rubbery same for carrots sweet
tender week we can do all that we can
control all of that in the systems that
we're discussing today so I think the
quality part of it and if if our
youngsters continue to say i'll give you
an extra nickel for that so that i can
make a living doing it then I think
everything becomes more fair everything
is going to work out I think that's
going to be it I ended with tomato so
many of us talked to made us today thank
you very much for the invitation this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu